one of the great pleasures I've had over
the last 45 years is to talk a lot to
senior media columnist editors and so on
who really have begun to grasp the
nature of this problem their questions
are much more probing much more
insightful I think the reporting has
gone a long way to make young people
aware of the dangers I think the for the
older audience they've provided
opportunities to explain the variety of
issues including the science I think you
know the media takes its hip off and
love but i would think on this one I got
to give them a lot of credit they really
have helped to get that message across
in a way I never would have been after
many years ago
member